hydration is super super important if  you hydrate well you can manage the heat  much much better if you turn on the  hydrating then you will  suffer very badly in the heat for sure  when it's very hot you drink  a lot anyway i don't think you need to  you know look out for what you're  drinking because you just constantly  want to drink  if anything i think actually  sometimes i need to be careful about  drinking too much  and then i get like a wishy-washy  stomach  ba certainly when it's really hot and  should be trying to drink almost two  balls an hour really especially if you  if you're sweating i mean the  advice is won't bother now but when it's  hot you need  try and get as much fluid in you as  possible